of it um so
so maybe in the last lecture i talked
about this basic stochastic museum
banded problem where we put a lot of
restriction we said
uh we play
we we can only pull one out of n arms we
only learn about the arm we pull we
learn learn about anything else the arm
distribution the reward is iid from a
fixed distribution that doesn't change
forever and so on so next we will look
at extensions that will remove every
single one of these assumptions
basically so we will we will look at
settings so contextual bandits where we
will remove the assumption that you
don't learn about any other arm we will
assume that there is similarities
between arms and when you pull arms you
can also infer information about other
arms
we will look at assortment selection
where you can pull more than one out of
an arms and the choice of the response
will depend on the set that you pull
rather than just the arm that you pull
in individually
we will remove the assumption that
all you care about is the regret in
terms of reward we will think about
constraints on the arms that you can
pull and the regret will be in terms of
some non-linear functions and so on and
that will give getting the third topic
later on tomorrow you will see the that
we will also remove the iid assumption
in the sense that the reward will depend
on what you have done in the past so in
in terms of the state and so you'll see
talks on reinforcement learning where
that will happen
so essentially we'll throw away the
basic formulation and put bells and
whistles on it
but amazingly the basic two basic
techniques we have learned will still be
applicable and we will be able to extend
them into handling much more general
formulations
right
so the first setting which is uh in my
view one of the most useful settings in
the sense that i have rarely seen
multi-arm bandwidth being applied
without considering contextual bandits
okay so here we think about uh the case
where there is lots of arms so you think
about searching a product on amazon even
if you put a simple thing like
headphones you'll sell see millions of
answers so you cannot imagine that you
can learn individually about every one
of them those headphones by showing
every headphone enough number of times
so you do want to think about learning
more than
the the thing that you show or the thing
that you play uh by using similarity and
this is a concept that's used in machine
learning all the time we want to learn
about similar things by watching one of
those
by watching the data about by looking at
data about one of those things
and what we do in machine learning to
allow that concept of similarity is
is something
it's called like for example in
supervised learning we use features
for so we describe uh an option or a
product by its features and then we say
that similar the products with similar
features must generate similar response
so we hope that in features we captures
their essential characteristics so that
if we know about a product with one set
of features
another product with similar features we
can hope that it will generate similar
response from a similar customer
okay so what we will do now is we will
we'll take that concept of features and
and models prediction models based on
these features and we'll incorporate
that into bandits
so
the basic setup that we will look at is
called contextual bandits so we will
describe arms by features
so here's the basic idea so think about
the setting with n arms still but now
think of very large number of arms
essentially you can also think of
continuous space of arms infinite arms
but to keep discussion simple let's
still think about discrete arms but
large number n is exponential or
whatever you can think about ultimately
we we might want regret bounds that
don't even depend on it okay
so but each arm is being described by a
context vector or a feature vector this
feature vector could be dependent on
both the arm and the time so it can
change with time even for the same arm
so for example imagine that on amazon
you are thinking about
showing a pr showing a particular
headphone to the customer and you might
want to describe that headphone by its
features like color and type and so on
whether it's noise cancelling or not but
this feature vector you might also want
to incorporate who you are showing it to
or when you are showing it so are you
showing it in the morning or in the
evening or in the night are you showing
it to a customer with certain
demographics or location or or a
customer who has already purchased very
expensive products in the past or very
cheap products in the past so if you
want to incorporate all that into your
features so then you can think of
constructing a feature vector that
depends on both the product i the arm i
and the time or the context of the
customer that you're showing showing it
to okay
so so this is the context vector and we
assume that the reward now is is doesn't
depend on just the product but it
depends on so the reward the expected
value is a dot product of the feature
vector and the unknown
the unknown
and an unknown vector mu so nu is this
parameter that is unknown that's the
unknown part of the distribution this is
now a vector okay
but this mu importantly is common among
all arms and all times so this is the
model parameter that you don't know it's
d dimensional but once you know this you
can map any feature vector to its reward
the expected reward okay so the expected
reward if you decide to pick one of the
so if you decide to play arm i which has
a feature vector x i t right now
let's call that feature vector as x t
the arm that you pull
then you know that the rewards mean will
be mu mu dot product of that feature
vector plus some noise and this noise is
id okay so this is the linear
bandit assumption and this this means
that your reward is generated from a
parametric model that depends linearly
on this unknown parameter vector and the
feature vector
so essentially your problem in terms of
information is to learn this unknown
parameter vector if you know this
unknown parameter vector then you know
what you should do at any time
irrespective of how many arms you have
and how their context change with time
if you knew the model the mu vector
then you could always decide what to do
at any time step by looking at all the
options available to you and pulling the
arm with the best
dot product okay and that is what we
define as the optimal thing to do
note that here the optimal thing is not
fixed across time so in the earlier
formulation we said if you do the model
you would always pull arm one all the
time or arm two all the time here what
you would do depends on the context the
time t
so you you will change what you do but
what doesn't change is the model you
still want to know the model to be able
to know what to do
so regret is now defined as what you
would do at time t if you knew the model
versus what you did do at time t without
knowing it or by by learning it
so you what is the expected reward you
would have gotten versus what you got
right any questions on the model
it does matter yeah
here we are assuming it is independent
uh if if it is the the noise model is
different for different arms
yeah you
you
you'll have
or something
so the question was that is does it
matter is it important that the noise
here doesn't depend on what you chose
and i believe it is
okay
so
so what is the
algorithm now and we will basically
extend our ucb algorithm to this setting
now so it always starts with so if you
think about ucb algorithm the general
technique if you apply it to any
extension is to first think about what
would you do if you didn't care about
exploration right what would you do as a
machine learning data
driven person who just has some data
some observations and you want to do the
best possible prediction right as a
frequentist at least so if you had some
data about rewards right so if you
observed some you you have somebody i
you don't know how why you decided to
make certain choices in the past but
whatever you did now you have some
observations you know what is the what
is the choices you made in the past the
feature vectors of the arms that you
pulled in the past and you know what the
rev what is the reward you got from it
okay so you know that the true model
satisfied something
like this sends the noise okay if you
ignore the noise the true model is
roughly linear with respect to the
context vectors you observed and the
rewards that you observe so true model
satisfies this roughly the system of
this system of equation based on your
past observations so if you didn't care
about exploration you would find the
best prediction of the true model using
let's say least square
regression right so if you minimize
least square error and fit a mu you
would get this mu hat estimation at time
t which will be has this standard x
expression like you solve an
optimization problem the optimal
solution is to find is b inverse uh sum
of these excess rs and b inverse b is
this matrix of uh it's all it has many
names one of the names is covariance
matrix of this estimator because it's
related to the variance in this
estimation okay
so so this is the standard solution of
the least square problem for the linear
model and you can show that
uh
even if these excess so it is easy to
show this error bound if this excess but
iid like independent or oblivious to
your to your observations in this case
they are not oblivious right because you
chose the next excess in the past based
on the previous observation and so on
they do form a martingale so
so so you have that so
slightly more complicated to show this
bound in the in the multi-arm band
setting but you can still use similar
techniques and show this self-normalized
tail inequality which says that the
estimator mu hat will be close to the
true and the error
in terms of this
matrix
matrix norm and the matrix is this
is this b matrix is bounded by
square root d log t roughly
okay
and this is important so this is bounded
with respect to the this matrix norm b
and this b is growing right so when i
say this is if i ignore the log t term
it's it's
this term is simply this term is much
smaller than the order of this term
right then this is growing with time
so you're bounding the er the error is
is becoming better and better with time
because even with the b norm it's
bounded by a fixed quantity almost fixed
quantity okay because b matrix is
growing with time
yeah
right so so this is a very non-trivial
bound this is roughly saying that the
the error
decreases
uh with time as one over square root the
number of trials
yeah
yeah just wondered what we added the
identity matrix to that summation is it
just so b would be invertible
yes
you can also have like lambda i here and
then talk about how it depends
assuming t is very large we don't care
about that
the question was why is there a one
identity matrix in the beginning
uh basically to make the invertible and
have nice arguments
yeah uh does it really seem like uh the
context is uh coming from
no so context is not so that's very
important thanks for pointing that out
this can be completely arbitrary
we make two important assumptions uh one
is you can see the context before making
the decision
and the second is uh the context is
oblivious it's not it doesn't depend on
your decisions right so they are
external
so think of them as
what customer came to see the product
what's the time of the day what's the
time what's the month of
you know all these set you have
available to you you know the future
vectors of the product so think about
what you're showing is that you're
deciding which products to show to the
customer
but you know the set you know the
features on that product you know which
customer you want to show them to
i think
they're not for the noise
you don't know the you don't know this
model you don't know
and then
show the almost optimal like maybe you
can show all the orthogonal feature
vectors once and then
find new yeah
yeah
i'm a little confused why
we call these arms like there's nothing
that ties an arm today to an arm
yesterday like the shirt
today on the ship yesterday could be
completely yes i i agree so in my most
of my papers i don't
use
i
uh so because the set can be completely
different every time yeah it just to
carry from the previous discussion i
kept it yeah you can have a completely
different end
at every time you might have a different
set of products available as long as
they have the same feature space
they're fine yeah
any other question
all right
so let's go ahead and see how we will
you will do the cb over this so we know
what we you will do if you just wanted
to find the best estimator right and you
will have a nice bound in terms of b
norm on this estimation
okay and
uh this this bound is somewhat
uh known from linear regression but it
was proven in the right uh like right
inequality as with all the dependencies
in these in these works which is which
was very important and useful
so what do you do in ucb the same idea
what we want to do is we want to find
pick an arm based on upper confident
estimate of its reward model okay so
here the reward model is is basically
mu transpose the
the x i t and i want what an upper
confidence bound on this on this mean
reward so what we do is we we only want
to develop an upper confidence one for
mu we don't want to develop an upper
confidence bound for every arm because
this number of arms is very large and as
nicole pointed out they could even be
changing this may not be a static set of
arms also so i really just want to
concentrate on finding a bound on mu and
use that to compute whichever arm set
i'm i'm given with
the best arm so what i do is in that
case actually there is no concept of
upper bound because mu
this is there is no monotonicity here i
don't want a necessarily an upper bound
because x could have arbitrary negative
positive features
so there's no concept of getting an
upper bound what i can say is that there
is a confidence interval a ball around
mu hat
where i know that optimal mu lies right
based on the error bound i know if i
form this ball around my estimate
the error bound ball then the optimal mu
the actual not optimal the the true
parameter mu lies in this ball ct okay
so now what i do is whenever i have to
make decision i basically select my arm
i don't know why it's not coming clear
here but
what this says is
i select my arm
based on finding the
or maximizing z transpose x where i
choose z in the ball and i choose i
so i choose both the features and the
parameter from the ball that maximizes
this dot product okay so because mu lies
in this ball
this will be more than mu transpose x i
t for every arm i right so i'm doing
so i'm doing max of z in this ball
and since mu lies in this ball this is
more than mu transpose x i t for every
arm i and therefore if i do max over i
this is like a ucb that i'm doing
right
so i pick my arm simply based on this
and now let's see why how can we bound
the regret of this algorithm
and the regret for this algorithm can be
bounded uh it has both expected regret
bound and high probability regret bound
i am using this old tilde notation to to
hide all the logarithmic terms because
they are more than one logarithmic terms
unlike the
an arm bandit here so i'm there's some
log n log t log one over delta
terms in here
but these are the the the sub linear
terms that are there so the important
thing to note here is that it doesn't
depend at all on the number of arms
and it depends linearly on the dimension
of the feature vector so the idea is
that since what you're learning is d
dimensional doesn't matter how many arms
you have to make decision among you you
information is only this
if you do have if you do know have a
finite number of arms you can get
slightly better uh better bound in terms
of log of n and t
so if you if you believe that n is
is not too much so you don't mind a
dependence on log n
then you can get a dependence on in
better dependence on the dimension
so if your n is finite then this might
be a use so if your context is changing
with time but number of arms is still
small this is a better better bound
okay
so
yeah
this is basically a
linear
adversary organic problem
it's not an adversary
so you can use the algorithm for the
linear underserved function
just like on a linear optimization
without this parenthesis but to solve
this problem
yeah let's let's talk about
so there's also a lower bound uh for for
this setting which is uh say which is
oh actually i miss site at the lower
bound i believe the lower bound is
square root dt for the finite arm case
not d not d square root t sorry
okay yeah it sounded like you said that
when you have finite number of arms you
can get log t regret is that right
or is it square root t regret
this one yeah yeah
no square root
like if you substitute n by exponential
in d then you can get this the same yeah
uh do you assume your feature method is
x
x x is not bounded but we assume the
reward
is sub gaussian or
so there are some assumptions i think
the assumption is mu is bounded has a
bounded norm and the reward is bounded
between zero one or its sub calcium
[Music]
it's one of the x's available to you so
this is the set of contexts available to
you you pick one of them to play and one
of them is the best thing to do
next car is the one that's best thing is
the context of the arm that's the best
one right now
and
xt is the context of the arm that you
put
you don't assume about it
not really like if you have reward
boundaries you don't need the um
how lucky are you that xt is not founded
so that cw is founded
yeah i mean you have to make a setting
like that but i'm saying that
technically you don't need it
i see so
you really have to
yeah i i don't know that there might be
a very structured process which can
generate such
such
rewards
yeah
might be sparse or
certain dimensions combine always
you always have two complementary things
yeah i don't want to rule out such
processes they're generated essentially
yeah so classic
problem
yes so
you can in fact i will discuss it in the
proof you can generate traffic 20 or
valid problem by saying x i t is just
like the indicator vector with r i
and mu vector is simply the vector of mu
1 2 u n
so then the then this is simply mu i
yeah
you still have a problem with the
independence of noise or something
you still have what
do you still have a restriction in what
what ordinary bandits fit into this
model because of the independence of
beta
[Music]
oh that's what you mean
i don't think that i think that that's
fine
but let me think about that yeah
human should be okay
uh
yeah so there might be generalizations
possible here
square root of n t right because the
dimension is n
so d is n in this case
no but that's instant specific this is
instance free so this is comparable to
the square root nt log t of the movement
so b is
all right let's move on so so i want to
just discuss like a high level of proof
here
um just so that like it demystifies a
little bit of what is happening here
right so so what is the regret here
so regret we said is the sum of over
time of what the optimal would do
minus what you did
okay the context you chose versus the
optima and
thing that we will do is use optimism
right so we you will use the fact that
we we didn't pick some arbitrary thing
we picked something very uh very smart
very specific so so the inequality we
will use is that x t star times mu
is in fact smaller than
uh
then what what we picked in the sense of
max
x t times
t times max over
z
so how do we show that is because the
the way we so first of all this is
smaller than
max over i
i t times
mu okay
simply by max property then we say this
is smaller than
max over
z slash in c t
i slash
in n
x i t times mu
and this is true because
x i t times z
so this is true simply because the
confidence intervals contains mu right
so because of that this is smaller and
and since we actually picked our arm to
play based on this so remember we picked
arm i for as r max of this term so this
is equal to max over z in c t
x t times c
okay
because our choice of of i
and z maximizes this dot product
so now that we have this
we will get almost what we want
great bound so let's take this
this is smaller than max over z in ct
we did this whole thing to make sure
that x t appears on both sides instead
of x t star and x d
which is because the context b played so
then we can bound the error in in the
estimation along the direction that we
observed
so here there was an error in the
direction of x t star versus an error in
the direction of x t
now now the error between z and mu is
both in the direction of x t
and we know what's the error between z
and mu is because z is in c d the
confidence ball that we have so we can
use that to say that this is smaller
then first of all we will
decompose it like this
let's call this as zt the the arg max of
this thing is zt
we we decompose this as the norm inverse
of bt
and the norm over bt
so the matrix norm with respect to bt
so bt was this covariance matrix and we
know that this is bounded
this was the error bound provided to us
by confidence interval by least square
estimate has this error bounded by
square root d log t
okay so we know that that anything in
the confidence interval is close in this
in this norm
so if you ignore this log t basically we
have a bound here that doesn't grow with
time
okay so this is a multiplicative term
here that we can ignore mainly we are
concerned about this part
so we are mainly concerned about
bounding this which is
x t transpose bt inverse
x t
okay so this is the
main term that we are concerned about
anything any bound we get on this
we will just multiply it by square root
d and get a regret bound so what is this
term here this is one of actually the
key
terms that will appear in any regret
analysis you will do and the beauty of
this term is that it now at this point
it doesn't even matter
how you chose your arms the the idea
that this bt is is is formulated in a
way that you will decrease your error no
matter what
so let's look at this term bt here
so bt remember is this matrix the
covariance matrix or the design matrix
um
as people call it
s equals 1 to t minus 1
x excess transpose
and the term you are interested is in x
t b t inverse x t
so what is happening here is that any
given time maybe this term is very large
you could say how do i know this term is
not very large
so this term could be very large in at
any given point why would this be large
probably if you think about this bt it
has large eigen values in the direction
in which no none of the excess is there
right so bt inverse will have large
eigen like a so this term it will result
into a large eigen value if there is no
excess that is in parallel to x t so
it's very orthogonal
all the previous
contexts that you observe are in
directions that are very orthogonal to x
t
that is a bad case okay
but why
but that is a in in a way it's good
because next because it means you kind
of explored in a direction x t which was
not observed so far
and that x t x t transpose is going to
get added to b t in the next step
so if this this term is big then in the
next term any x t parallel to this x t
will result in a small term okay so
you're kind of if you're losing right
now because your xt is very orthogonal
to the previous axis you will gain all
the time in the future because now if
you see any feature vector parallel or
close to parallel to this one you'll
have a small term so every loss right
now is information gained for the future
and to see that very precisely let's
look at the example that uh the
gentleman here pointed out think about
this xtis which are one eye right so
it's like
let's say static context like the
multi-unbanded setting
with only one in the feature vector is
simply one in the ith
entry and rest everywhere
in that case what happens is bt is
simply this
if you think about what excess excess
transpose is it's simply one one
transpose which means one entry in the
diagonal at s and zero everywhere so bt
simply is n one t
and two t
number of plays that you did for every
arm
and zero everywhere okay so this is your
your bt plus one i mean i ignored the
plus one but yeah plus one everywhere so
this is what bds so what is this weird
looking term there in that setting this
weird looking term is simply
square root of 1 i
b t
inverse 1 i it's nothing but our
familiar term
nit
okay
so this term here is nothing there but
this in the multi-unbended setting
so what you are trying to mean to to
bound here
in the multi-arm bandwidth setting is so
this if you're trying to bound the sum
you're trying to bound this
so now let's look at why this term is
bounded now i don't even have to say
that how i played these arms that are i
grows fast enough or not you can show
that this term will always be bounded
irrespective of how you chose the arms
because there's only so much you can do
right so there's always information you
will gain so if you look at this term
[Music]
okay so let's divide it based on time on
based on arms i equals one to n let's
look at time at which i was played okay
i just rewrote that thing like this
right so i just summa summed over i and
just look at the time steps at which i
was played what does this term this term
every time the i is played and it
increases by one
so this is simply
so this is simply 1 over 1 plus 1 over
square root 2 plus 1 over square root 3
and so on till 1 over square root nit
okay
so now this simply sums up to square
root n i t
roughly right
so
or less let's say less than equal to
now what is the worst value of this
there are only t trials
how can you make this the largest
possible is to just have equal number of
players of because this is like a
function that's maximized if nit was all
one over and t over n
okay so the worst value of this is if
every one was t over n
and that's square root n t
so basically this is
what is happening except it's very easy
to see in the multi-unit setting because
you can see that every time you have a
large value you and you play that arm
you see a decrease in the next term and
then the next term in the next term but
the same thing is happening here
whenever you have a large value of xt bt
inverse it means bt does not have
anything in that direction which means
you gain by adding this in and decrease
the next term and the next term and so
on okay
and this
intuition is basically formalized in in
peter hours proof uh lemma where they
show that the eigen values decrease
every time by a certain amount and
therefore the sum always is bounded and
in fact that one lemma is kind of used
in almost all the proofs of linear
bandits to show this last term is
bounded okay
all right any questions
yeah
why isn't there like dependence
supposed to be like the noise um
added to the
uh the dark product oh we are just
everything is normalized to one
yeah if there is a
bound of l
or a spread of l in the noise you will
scale everything back up
any other questions
if you have any doubts about proof let
me know because the other next one will
depend on this one so the sequential
dependence
this matrix bt
changes over time
it is this matrix
yeah
it grows live
yes
uh
somebody is not found
no i mean it's it's bounded by t yeah
it's growing every step yes then the
ligand values are increasing
yeah so that's why i was emphasizing the
significance of of this bound right so
it is growing but the error is rounded
because you're also new is you're
getting more and more samples so mu is
getting closer to that so this bound is
not saying the error between you and
your head is fixed
it's saying it's decreasing big time
because the norm is the norm that you
are taking with respect to that matrix
is growing so you are actually news
getting closer to muhat but in this
direct these directions
since i mean
so it's like that's why i like to think
of the example of the bandits right so
there we say that
mu i minus mu hat
is less than 1 over square root whatever
n
so this is basically saying u minus mu
times square root of m is less than a
constant
that's what this is yes but here it's t
not
matrix norm so it's x transpose b x
very fast
x is
oh okay so you are right in that sense
that is probably assumed that the c
depends on the norm of x or something
or it relies on the fact that x
transpose mu is founded
assume that x transpose
because it's not this term involves new
minus mu
yes there are probably some assumptions
there to make sure that everything is
let's assume for now that x is bounded
okay x is bounded mu is bounded yeah i'm
sure there are there are small
extensions possible
yeah i don't want to get into that
rabbit hole of finding the right set up
yeah one of the key difficulties
including this is that this is
this is a
not a constant right so this is also
depends on these and these are not iid
so it's a self-normalized so this is
also
generated from the stochastic process
it's a marketing area so which one are
you using
what are you using
it's like i they've proved using basic
uh like
derivational markov inequality and then
proving using exponential
and so on
they use like exponential functions yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right so moving on so now if you
want to do it seems like i'll only be
able to do contextualities today but if
you want to do now thousand sampling uh
the the idea is is very similar you you
do the basic step the same way you
compute a least square estimator you had
and then instead of uh instead of
instead of forming this confidence ball
and finding the extreme point in this
bowl so you remember in the in the uh in
the ucb you found the contrast ball and
then you said find the maximum i and and
the estimate in the ball the combination
of which maximizes x transpose mu so
you're finding an extreme like on the
boundary of this ball basically an
extreme point where the x transpose mu
is maximized and you're playing
according to that so similar idea to ucb
where you found the extreme point of the
confidence interval and played according
to that so now instead of doing that you
basically put a distribution on this
pawn so you say that let's look at the
our estimate and and the posterior you
can again show using bayes rule that the
posterior will be of this form but you
can show posterior at any time assuming
gaussian prior will be the gaussian with
the mu mu hat computed the same way as
we computed here the least square
estimator
and the the the mean of the posterior
will actually be the least square st
error estimator and the covariance turns
out to be
the
the covariance matrix and this this fact
is not like so now there are various
things in which these kind of things
appear where the posterior is actually
has the covariance matrix as this which
is some by some sometimes this is
referred to as covariance matrix okay
but we use that to design a from the
sampling algorithm where we say that now
instead of choosing a mu in this ball as
an extreme point sample a mu
from this gaussian and then make your
decision based on the sample parameter
okay so you simply
uh use the sample mutilda from the from
this gaussian multivariate gaussian and
you take the action that maximizes the
dot product of your sample and the so
you basically remove that other max
where you were doing max over the
confidence ball and you simply max the
sample
okay
and we have to make the proofs work we
give a small boost here which is like
some logarithmic boost
right
i will not go through the proofs of this
one it has some complications in the
sense that uh you don't have this first
step basically so you can do this step
because you don't have optimism so you
have to kind of say that uh you don't
you don't play optimistically but you do
play the good arm enough and so on so
but let's not go into that
but we can prove uh basically
a bound which is comparable so we
instead of d we have these d raised to 3
by 2 so next extra square root d
in fact it's not clear so far if this
square root d can be removed to the best
of my knowledge
there is like
this algorithm achieves the lower bound
but
there are settings in which this
algorithm is not polynomial time this
one is so it's not clear and there are
other polynomial time algorithms
which also have d square d raised to
three by two so it's not even clear if
there is a polynomial time algorithm
that can get you
the lower bound the information
theoretically overbound so this is
something that is a very niche problem
but very cute problem if someone wants
to discuss with me later on uh
let me know okay
so there are other contextual
formulations in particular you can uh
generalize the linear bandit to a very
useful setting where you still have
linear model but you also have a one one
dimensional function like a one single
argument function over that linear model
so your your reward may be a non-linear
function of that linear
parametric function so you might have
log mu transpose x for example right and
then depending on the lipschitz
constants and things like that you
cannot still get uh regret bounds using
similar techniques and there are even
further generalizations like
uh
like you just have some function not
even non-linear function on a matrix
space and you want to just
do a general
exploration of the metric space adaptive
exploration of the metric space and
those techniques are different from ucb
for example here they use a zooming
algorithm with generally which assumes a
general metric space and zooms into the
right parts of the metric space to do
exploration
and if you're interested just look at
those
those references i think some of the
authors will also be here during the
program and you can talk to them
so i want to briefly mention in the last
10 minutes uh to anyone who has any
questions about the linear bandits
before i move on maybe one quick
question no okay
yeah
frankly i don't remember exactly what it
was right now uh it has been a while
i believe it's long ethnic but i may be
like don't cut me on it yeah i have to
look up and see what it was
how important did you ask how important
it was
so in in in
the experiments we did we never use the
boost and it works
but for groups it's important so that's
my best answer
but experiments are never like you can
change the setting and maybe it won't
work in some sense
okay so i want to discuss a little bit
to other formulations one is assortment
optimization and assortment optimization
is actually a very classic problem in or
where you think about
presenting an assortment of products and
then think about externality that they
impose another part so you don't want to
say that oh if i product present product
i it will be selected with probability
pi you want to think about the set you
give and how that affects a person's
choice behavior because if there is a
very expensive product place with very
cheap products that expensive product
may appear even more expensive than
it was presented alone so those kind of
externalities if you think about them
then the probability that a customer
chooses a product i
that you see a click or a question or
product i from the set s
may not get made it may be may not be
defined in terms of just some pi or pj
right so it might be some complicated
function
of this set that we're presenting so
this makes the problem a combinatorial
problem because in order to learn
the choice probability of product i you
have to kind of present different within
different combinations to be able to
learn about
and in general this could be very hard
if you have no structure on how a set
affects the choice probability of a
particular product therefore you might
want to think about some structural
assumptions so that you can make the
problem simpler
so one structure assumption is to
skip over the examples i'm sure you all
can imagine the examples in which such
externalities will occur
so one structure which is a very classic
model in or
is is to think about
the and and in fact it's it's popular
elsewhere as well it's the logic model
it's a multinomial logic model which is
uh
you think about
the assumption basic assumption of the
dependence of irrelevant in fact you can
see true that roughly if you assume
independence of the irrelevant
alternatives this is the model you would
come up with so independence of 11
alternatives means that the relative
choice probability of two products
doesn't change based on who you
presented with so so the pi over pj is
same across the sound so just because
the third product was presented i don't
start liking this product compared to
this other one more
so in particular in this in this
in this model you see that p i over p j
is same for all the sets it's always e
raised to theta i over e raised to theta
j it doesn't matter what set is
presented but but if you talk about a
particular choice probability of product
i
then it is a normalized version of the
products that represent the index
and this one is basically thought of as
the
probability of known choice
so so the probability of making no
choice is one over the sum and the rest
of them have this
choice probability
right so here the the idea is
uh that
the model is nice because now
even though the problem is combinatorial
in the sense that you could potentially
be thinking about two raised to n
possible sets that you want to learn
about but the model is parametric with
only
either one
so if you know these n parameters then
you could always then you can select
expect to present without going through
all possible cognitive set of choices
okay so now you go back to your example
of like contextual band is there also we
said that even though there could be
many arms here the arms think of arms as
the possible sets that we could show to
the customer
which is combinatorial but if you know
this one the d-dimensional parameter
then we could choose any times what's
the optimal thing to do same way here if
i know this n dimensional parameter i
could choose which of these
combinatorially many sets to present to
the customer
because that would be the optimal set in
terms of the choice maximizing some kind
of revenue given the choice problem
so what are we trying to maximize here
so we we think about this problem where
you have n products they have these
unknown parameters you want to recommend
a product a set assortment of products
of size at most k so it's a limited
capacity
choice
and then you observe a revenue rit the
revenue is basically
expected revenue
is basically the the ri there's a [ __ ]
ri revenue you assume you know the what
you will get if you if customer
purchases so you have a product it has a
price if the customer purchases it you
know the revenue you will make so ri is
known but you don't know whether the
customer will in fact choose it or not
so this is the revenue you will get if
you show a set as of products
and
so you observe an instantiation of that
revenue and based on that you want to do
an estimation of the parameters theta of
the model
and your goal is to maximize the total
so if you think about the contextual
value example the problem is not very
different it's just the model is
different right so you are now
presenting something uh
a set which has a parameter unknown
parameter vector
and you want to learn this an unknown
parameter vectors you can do a best next
one like you would estimate of this
parameter from your observations but
then you don't want to play according to
those you want to do some ucb your
thousands happening over that parameter
to make your choice that basically that
is basically the idea uh with some
issues so
so so there are some issues of getting
an
estimate of theta because you only
observe the product that was purchased
you don't
get feedback the whole feedback of other
products and so on but uh but it's it's
an extension of the same same techniques
you for ucb
you can get uh square root and d bounds
and same horizontal sampling but one of
the things interesting things about this
paper is that you don't get a nice
conjugate
behavior here because what happens is
you have a fire on theta then you
observe a sample from this model and the
posterior is not as directly
number as it was in terms of language
setting so you have to do a posterior
approximation so we do a gaussian
approximation of the posterior to give
the balance
uh the final topic i want to mention and
won't spend too much time on it but i
just wanted to put it out there so that
if you're wondering oh i have a
bandwidth problem but it has these
constraints and it has this only reports
i want to say
most of it has been done already
so uh
so one of the things that you might have
been uh wondering is okay we have this
total number of pools of steam but you
could potentially put
the same arm might be the solution might
be pull the same arm all the time and
that seems very impractical most of the
time nobody pulls like shows one product
all the time so how what is going wrong
here
it's because we didn't put any
constraints on how much you can use a
particular arm or how much
or other constraints on how diverse you
want the location to be or there are
some advertisers who want to show their
ad so you even if an ad generates the
most interest you can't keep just
showing
one ad all the time because you want to
make other advertisers happy as well or
or they have limited budgets and so on
so how do we incorporate all those
things here
so what you want to think about is first
of all constraints so you want to say
yeah you want to put the best arm but
the restrictions like you can't pull the
even if you know this is the best time
you can't do it all the time there might
be budget constraints
or
you might also want to think about the
rewards may not be just the sum of
rewards maybe there is a there is a
fairness constraint like you want to
minimize the max or you want to maximize
the main reward
of different entities that were involved
or you want to think about the uh
not just like if i'm doing an ad or
showing search results maybe you want to
maximize the satisfaction of the
customers so you want to maximize the
minimum satisfied customer or something
like that so there might be different
non-linear
objectives that you want to put on
aggregate rewards and these so so when
you pull an arm you might see different
kinds of rewards right so you might see
that yes you pulled an arm which made
the advertiser this much happy and
customer this much happy now there are
two entities
so which one do you want to maximize
maybe you want to have some combination
of advertiser happiness and customers
happiness or sellers happiness and your
buyer's happiness so how do you combine
those into
non-media rewards
so the general setting uh
that that one we can solve at this point
is think about whenever you put an arm
you generate a d dimensional vector now
whether it's a reward vector or a cost
vector
let's not discuss that it's just a d the
directional vector of observations
now your your objective could be
some function of the aggregate of this d
dimension so maybe the first two
components of this d-dimensional vector
is the reward and your objective might
be the mean of the two rewards okay we
may not advertiser rewards and the
uh and the buyer's
seller's reward in the past for example
or there might be
that that there might be some
demographics and you want to say there
are four communities and you aggregate
the rewards of different communities and
different components of that vector and
you're going to say maximize the mean of
these four different countries as a the
variables required
so the this is all allowed as long as f
is a concave function for example main
is a conjugate function itself
the other you can also put constraints
on so maybe the last 10 components of
that vector are cos and you can say that
the sum of the cost should lie in some
context
or
or
any
yeah any convex set which means you can
put the context function on that
vector and put some constraint on that
so if you have that
then again you can use a
uh use a ucd you have to be a little
careful of designing but again the idea
of having a confidence
ball still works
so you basically think about your vector
of observations and you can develop a
confidence interval of each component of
that vector
and you can simply say that every time
you want to pull an arm meaning the
decisions that you want to take you you
take that based on the probability
vector p
which maximizes your whole constraint
optimization problem
so you think about your confidence
intervals of the vector and you say that
find the
maximize
so this is like the double maximization
that we
did in ucb right we said maximize over
arms but also maximum we are estimating
the confidence for so same thing i am
doing here i am maximizing over the
estimating the ball and i am finding the
best p here i'm minimizing because it's
a constraint
so i'm finding the most hesitant
estimating stuff
but it's the same idea as what we saw in
contextual setting you take a confidence
interval and find the worst or the best
estimate
and you can show that doing that
you can have a regret
which uh which is similar order as we
saw in the independent settings
and
but we we also have in general there is
a regretting constraint which means
constraint might be violated by this
point
you can
have like constraint must be satisfied
constrained like if you want the
constraint have to be satisfied you can
do it in general basically what can
happen if your if your constraint site
is such that you can go in and out of it
all the time
then you then you i don't think it's
possible to avoid this part but you have
a constraint set which always you
approach from downwards for example if
you have a budget constraint then you
always are within the budget and at some
point you might exceed it so there's a
proper definition of this convex set
which is like a downward force set
so if you have such a constraint which
has some body and you always approach it
from bottom at some point you might
exceed it and this may not be just
budget constraint you can have any such
ball or anything but there's a body of
the ball and
you always approach it from below
then you can achieve uh without so you
can avoid things you can make sure
you're always within the constraints
because you're starting from the bottom
and you can make sure you never exceed
the
exceed the boundary and you can get a
regret from the objective for example
for budget constraints
so that was a very very quick overview
sorry
about that about the extensions but
hopefully i provided you pointers if you
are interested you can look up these
papers and see if they apply to you
thank you
i'm also on the coffee break if people
want to come in there
i've seen some of this stuff before but
still
like i think every time we see this
tutorial you learn something new from it
so
uh that's a great start to this program
but we're gonna continue after lunch so
we we gonna be not too
um so
we're gonna switch to this was more
about the stochastic side we're gonna
switch after lunch to thinking about the
serial side of bandwidth